that she doesn't claim to be Sufi or
anything but there is this idea that uh
all sufis are all one and the same and
that's not I don't understand so your
mom's not Sophie what you mentioned that
she's not Sufi but in terms of like you
know she's the worshiper you mean yeah
I'm saying look this term was used
um
like using the term zahid someone who's
there hitting the Dunya you know
assistant English
uh
aesthetic yeah yeah ascetic or something
yeah yeah
it's known what is used for
I mean like uh that's why I said name is
now you know because
if you ask my family back home whoever
people like Pakistan or India or Somalia
comes from ignorance
uh and so you see practices happening
there and even you know people uh you
know within Pakistan and India will see
that and they'll say these people are uh
Hill People yes
that doesn't reflect what circuit or the
sufis of the hotel
I know I don't know all I know is my
sweet brother we want to live from
because you just he's explained yeah
it's in the right path
that we know now Sophia or before that
as different Sophia you know where they
came from some say you come from
the world government yeah so and they
say it goes back to
uh
it was a son of a king then once he was
walking and the story is very similar to
Buddha
that he was the son of a rich man and uh
and he went out and he saw a rich he was
from a rich family and he saw a poor
person so this that's why a lot of
people say suvism the right foreign
foreign
except Allah
Unity
everywhere we go
we go that's why we have
Allah without anything yeah without any
closing their man and saying he's my
mawla it doesn't work mawlana
means
no
problems yeah
so what I'm saying to you brother this
Mission which sushi
it's not having good death category he
just told you to go to the Grave is or
to go to the mola somebody and just ask
for bless
yeah I think what brother was saying
yeah
that's that's more of the meaning of
what I think of sushi as well someone
who would stay away from Dunya stay away
from Dunya and I think I think the word
Sufi gets mixed about so much yeah I
don't even think sufis who feel that
their SUVs call themselves
except this thing is that even is not
even legislative term
you know I mean like I tell you story
yeah
back home
so there was this so-called yeah
when a woman needs to go to him he used
to ask them remove your goals remove the
gold the chain the bracelet everything
then he smack them you know I mean it
breaks the the chains and everything
yeah
he took it
people say because you can be someone
just nice
I have a nice car and you say it as us
what is the meaning of Zaid he said it
doesn't mean you don't just lie so
nothing said me that if you dress nice
you do not attach your heart to the uh
the material things garment
foreign